the same vaccine could not work you take  a solid flu vaccine you don't think that  would have an impact or much of an  impact on corona no cummings district is  a disgusting rat and rodent infested  mess  [Music]  compared to other presidents trump has  golfed more than any modern president  cnn should be ashamed of itself having  you working for them you are a rude  terrible person trump showed up and  started throwing paper towels to people  like he was shooting free throws in  basketball donald trump's decision to do  the corona caravan drive around walter  reed well it's not the hardest task no  but it has a picture and it says and  it's an element no no  you see that's all misrepresentation  well that's what the white house had put  together a statement praising mccain and  his life and his heroism trump said no  no statement i'll post a tweet instead